okay so this person what so many people
tagged me in this this person is has
just finished a four day darkness
Retreat oh one of these so they've they
haven't seen light
like they go in that little cabin yeah
you can't see [__] for four days which I
think this is what Aaron Rodgers did yes
and then he made he goes I'm gonna go to
the New York Jets
I've decided to end my career
she's wearing wow
what
wow
the madness
of the Mind
it's met with this ocean of love
there isn't anything you can do but
surrender to it again and again and
again
all right
just just mental breakdown simulator
that's all this is dude now mental
breakdown simulator
uh so
what we're gonna do is challenge
your entire notion of sense
your sense of self and then just toss
you back yeah yeah we're good so we're
gonna do that for four day straight and
I'm just gonna put you back outside yeah
and see what happens let's film your
reaction yeah she's just saying all that
crazy [__]
just so her brain is like ah sunlight
we're good this is a cure we met with
this wave of the man the love the brain
just hitting all the buttons man oh
[__] thank God yeah we're [__]
back we're back Boys fire it up
it's our mind just reason
the mat The Love The Madness of the
month
it's a hard restart yeah yeah she's
booting up the login items you're met
with this Spotify
please start singing There's No salsa in
my burrito
[Laughter]
then a little chuckle to reset
wow you just have to engage it again and
again oh is this an account of these
this company does this is what they do
this is their service
yeah Joe Kirby's music
[Music]
it is so beautiful
this is a picture of [__] John Hamm
on the TV yeah yeah
you're just there oh my God
they're just in a studio just one of the
main maintenance guys like yeah bent
over yeah the last crack is coming out
what's up what's up hmm so beautiful the
way the way the cheeks
can join but are separate and the hair
stop crying in my ass yeah I'm crying on
my ass that's to them on their phone
first yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
custom on this on the [__] yeah the
bus home yeah whatever like shuttle they
had to take to get out here so yeah
there's like three things with their
Instagram notifications like this is way
better yeah yeah
they're little I missed so much [__]
they're a little rat brain just
I'm sure these reactions are genuine but
yeah you sit in darkness for four days
you're probably gonna cry should we do
this
just sit in darkness how do you know
I'll do Darkness Retreat I remember yes
Theory did this
did our boy cry when he exited
I don't know okay pause it for a second
how do you like how is this actually
possible without like going insane
I I think a certain amount of time is
okay what'd you say a certain amount of
time is probably okay
yeah like it's probably like a fight or
flight thing where your brain can
sustain it for a short period
but like I always thought like sensory
deprivation tanks like people can only
do them for like a couple hours at most
how do you do five days
and how do you what do you do in there
maybe this is wildly dangerous and we'll
find out like three years because I
thought like you kind of lose track of
time yeah but those are different than
this like sensory decorations like and
you're floating and they're like it's
like nothing this is like you just can't
see
to New Beginnings here we go just hits a
wall yeah
wow we'll come out into the world
the colors are so vibrant
oh so yeah
[Music]
the enlightened one so I feel like
that's a genuine reaction true
great College I I swear to God I swear
last night I said colors I missed the
most yellow and green okay here we go
today I felt such peace that I've just
never experienced before in my life
completely surprised myself with this
one well I I didn't know what to expect
I just I didn't think I could do it
colors are so quick your eyes look like
the Wolves eyes to me right now that's
great I swear I don't have breakthrough
moments where you were up against the
challenge or something that really moves
you through okay yeah yeah because I was
but then they wouldn't sell tickets if
that's what the reaction was yeah I know
dude walks out and he's like wow whoa
yeah this is sick
yeah
colors green is green yeah
yeah your eyes look sick thanks dude
yeah no problem anyways there's Taco
Bell down the way oh let's hit that yeah
I miss alcohol though
is it I you know let's go get blacked
out yeah it's just on a bender the whole
time in there oh yeah [__] hammered
it's been five [__] days no wonder my
head hurts holy [__]
I know
and she covers her eyes back up she's
like I don't want to go into the light
she's having an orgasm God
she about to come dude holy [__] that's
why she's not opening them she's like
I'm so close
ah
a
no no she's she's masking it
she's like I'm gonna have to cry because
this big O is coming
[Music]
don't you think like this this is like a
bad sign like it just means a
everything's gotten too good where we're
just gonna create these like yeah pain
simulators I mean I'm not the first one
isn't that what a coal plunge is too
yeah I'm not the first person to say
this I know other people have but I you
know that's the conclusion I drew about
like haunted houses yeah okay well it's
like annually it's like
nothing scary nothing's really that's
scary
I'd like to go through like an insane
asylum for pretend I guess it's a good
thing what that nothing isn't it I I
think or is it a bad thing no I um I
think in the Western World we're
probably out of touch yeah I think
that's what it is that we
you know we turn everything into a
product yeah you want to pay to be in
darkness
yeah
pay to feel like you're down in the
mines yeah